Monsieur Kourkov, bonsoir.
- Vous avez quitté Kiev pour
vous réfugier avec votre famille
dans un endroit plus sécuritaire
choisi de rester?
ANDREÏ KOURKOV, écrivain
- De rester en Ukraine?
le pays. Et en fait, il y a
beaucoup de gens restés aussi à
Kiev. Je leur téléphone chaque
avec des conversations avec
mes... par téléphone
avec mes amis dans des endroits
Mais bien sûr, je suis pas loin
de la frontière avec la Hongrie
dans le moment et on est ici p u
voyager pour faire une
collection d'argent pour
les réfugiés, organiserénénénénr
l'Ukraine.
- Est-ce que vous restez aussi
pour témoigner de ce qui se
passe comme
ce matin?
- - - Bien sûr. Bien sûr. J'écrs
beaucoup de textes chaque jour à
Donbass, à Kharkiv, à Marioupol,
à Odessa. J'ai suivi tout ce qui
se passe m
- Oui. Justement, parlez-nous
donc de cette guerre.
Ça fait trois semaines déjà.
Que savez-vous de la situation à
Marioupol, qui résiste toujo
- Oui, mais c'est une ville
détruite. En fait, maintenant,
Marioupol remplace dans
l'histoire de notre région
la bataille de Stalingrad, parce
que c'est c'est la même vision,
c'est la mêlelelele détruite
avec beaucoup de gens morts
sur les routes et impossible
de les enlever, parce qu'il y a
un bombardement chaque,
chaque heure, chaque 30 minute.
- Mais la ville refuse de se
rendre et la mobilisation des
Ukrainiens, cette volonté qu'ils
ont de résister, ça a sidéré
le monde entier. D'ou vient,
M. Kharkov, cet esprit de
résistance des Ukrainiens,
ce fort sentiment national?
- Oui, en fait, Poutine a
consolidé la nation ukrainienne
et pour les Ukrainiens,
la liberté est plus importante
que la stabilitéoau l'argent
ou aussi que la vie, parce qu'on
comprend que s'il n'y a pas
d'Ukraine libre, les Ukrainiens
ne seront pas libres aussi.
Et comme ça, cette résistance,
c'est le signe que les
Ukrainiens veulent être
les habitants d'un pays libre,
indépendant et européen et ils
ne veulent pas rejoindre l'Union
soviétique à nouveau, ce que
M. Poutine essaie de faire.
- Oui. Mais ils se battent
seuls. L'Occident refuse
toujours de s'engager davantage.
On dit que c'est par peur de
déclencher une troisième guerre
mondiale. Qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez? Est-ce que ça
vous déçoit?
- Bien sûr, bien sûr, mais il y
a un peu des aides militaires,
des aides aussi pour les
réfugiés qui ont reçu déjà
des pays européens. Mais il y a
des pays qui sont trop passifs
et continuent à avoir la
commerce avec la Russie. C'est
comme l'Allemagne, par exemple.
Je crois que les politiciens
allemands, ils ne veulent
pas rejoindre les sanctions
plus graves contre la Ru
Mais en fait, c'est déjà la
guerre troisième mondiale,
parce que, par exemp
30 minutes, l'avion militaire
russe traversait la frontière
avec la Pologne e e e e e e e va
pas rester une guerre qu'entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie dans
le territoire ukrainien.
Je s ç ç ç ç ç ç ç ça.
- Et vous pensez que Vladimir
Poutine, que vous avez souvent
vovovovovovovovos livres ou dans
des conférences ou dans des
entrevues avec les journalistes,
crcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcritiqué depuis
longtemps. Est-ce que vous
pensez que Vladimir Poutine vaj?
- Oui, je suis sûr de ça, parce
qu'il est vieux. La seule choser
dans les livres scolaires
d'histoire de Russie commequelqt
l'Union soviétique, qui a
reconstruit l'Empire russe
et créé un État de qui tous
les autres pays ont peur, parce
qu'il ne s'intéresse pas dans le
destin des soldats russes tués.
Il ne s'intéresse pas dans
l'économie russe, qui est aussi.
- Vous, vous êtes né à Saint-
Pétersbourg, M. Kourkov, d'un
père russe. Votre grand-pè
était un héros de l'Armée rouge
et vous écrivez, d'ailleurs,
vos romans en russe.
Est-ce que c'est difficile
de vivre cette double identité
en ce moment pour vous?
- Ce n'est pas une d
identité juste. J'ai une
identité ukrainienne, je ne suis
pas un Ukrainien ethnique,
je suis un Ukrainien politique
et je suis le citoyen d'Ukraine.
Il y a plus que 7 millions
ethniques russes, ici, qui sont
des Ukrainiens. En fait, les
premières victimes civiles de
cette guerre dans l'est du pays,
dans le sud du pays, c'est
plutôt les russophones et les
Russes qui sont des citoyens
d'Ukraine.
- C'est vrai. Vous dites querest
des russophones, justement.
- Oui.
- À Kharkiv ou dans les villess.
- Marioupol, 98 % des gens là
sont aussi des Grecs, des
Russes, des Ukrainiens.MaMaMaMa.
- Et vous dirigez aussi
la section ukrainienne
du PEN Club International.
C'est l'organisation d'écrivains
en faveur de la liberté
d'expression. Quelle a été
jusqu'à présent la réaction des
écrivains russes? Qu'est-ce que
vous entendez dire de ce qu'ils
voient, de ce qu'ils savent
de cette guerre?
- Oui, il y a une lettre ouverte
publiée dans la littérature
The Gazette à la Gazette
littéraire de Moscou, où
beaucoup d'écrivains russes
soutiennent Poutine et
soutiennent cette guerre.
Il y a aussi une lettre contre
la guerre et contre l'agression
russe, signée par les écrivains
qui, à partir de la position...
comme Vladimir Sorokine,
Dmitri Bykov, Boris Akounine.
Mais la majorité des gens de la
culture russe, ils soutiennentle
toujours et on n'a pas reçu
des messages de soutien du côtéb
ukrainien.
- Même vos amis. Vous devez
avoir des amis écrivains russes,
no
- Non... Si, j'ai quelques amis.
Je sais qu'ils soutiennent
i i i i i i i i i i i i i pas
reçu des messages de mes amis
de Russie.
- Vous s
certains prônent un boycottage
de l'ensemble des artistes
russes en Occident pour
accentuer la pression sur
le Kremlin. Est-ce que c'est
la bonne chose à faire? Est-ce
onononononononononononononon vo?
- La majorité des écrivains
ukrainiens sont pro-boycott des
cultures russes complètement.
Je pense qu'il y a bien sûr des
gens qui soutiennent l'Ukraine
et ne soutiennent pas Poutine.ss
les boycotter. Il faut soutenir
les gens comme ça, comme
Vladimir Sorokine.
- Parce que sanctionner
des artistes qui ont justement
manifesté leur oppositionààààààt
quand même, quoi, on ne peut pas
pénaliser l'ensemble, hein?
- C'est très im
eeeeeeeeeeeeeee
sais aussi que les Ukrainiens,
les écrivains ukrainiens ne sont
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s ac
des gens, avec des écrivains
russes qui soutiennent
émotionnellement, c'est
impossible maintenant de parler.
- Quand cette guerre sera
terminée, pensez-vous que cepops
et les Ukrainiens de vivre
encore côte à côte?elelelelelelt
brisé avec ce qui se passe?
- Peut-être après 20 ou 30 ansse
politique de la Russie.
- Mais pas avant.
- Mais pas avant, non.
- Et ça, est-ce que vous pensez,
vu de l'Ukraine, est-ce que
vous pensez que la pressionpopoa
finalement pouvoir fragiliser
Vladimir Poutine? Est-ce que
c'est ça qui v
- Je ne sais pas, je ne sais
pas. Au moment, j'ai lu que
80 % des Russes soutiennent
le président Poutine dans sa
politique à propos de l'Ukraine.
- Et vous, là, vous allez rester
en U
bombardements se rapprochent
de vous?
- Oui jusqu'au d
Si ça devient trop dangereux,
bien sûr, je vais quitter le
pays, mais
ça.
- Vous voulez rester?
- Ou
- C'est important pour vous,
pour les Ukrainiens.
tous les Ukrainiens.
Ne quittez pas le pays.eaeaeaeap
de femmes et des enfants
qui sont maintenant réfugiés
en Europe. Mais il y a aussi
320 000 hommes ukrainiens
qui sont revenus de l'étranger
pour défendre le pays. s s s s s
avez toute notre admiration.
On regarde jour après jour, onst
on vous souhaite bon courage.
- Merci.ovovovovovovovovovovovo.
- Au revoi